Das ist ein richtiger sensationsfund und das gleich aus mehreren gründen der riesige schwarze granit sarkophag ist nicht nur alt sondern wohl auch der größte
sarkophag der jemals in alexandria in ägypten entdeckt wurde er wurde ende juni bei bauarbeiten in fünf metern tiefe gefunden
und forschungsteams vermuten dass er seit der antike nicht mehr geöffnet wurde eine echte seltenheit
jetzt wurde er geöffnet im science fiction herzlich willkommen
Wenn ihre geschichten wie die mumie oder
mamis erkenntnis der dass dort eindringlich davor gewarnt wird die letzten ruhestätten der ägypter zu stören doch das
wissenschaftliche interesse geht vor denn es ist so so selten genug dass gräber der antike gefunden werden die noch ungeöffnet sind tatsächlich
sind die meisten von ihnen bereits vor jahrhunderten von grabräubern geplündert worden um kostbare grabbeigaben
zu klauen nicht so bei dem aktuellen fund aus alexandria das amt
ministerium hatte am ersten juli verkündet dass bei bauarbeiten in einem stadtteil nahm sie die gabe der wohl größte derartige
fund in der region gemacht wurde der sarkophag aus
schwarzem gestein ist ganze zwei meter 65 lang 1 meter 65 breit und 1 meter 85 hoch
und zudem scheint er wie gesagt ungeöffnet denn die
mittelschicht an den seiten des deckels ist noch komplett intakt so gehen forschungsteams davon aus dass er wohl seit etwa
2000 jahren verschlossen ist das ägyptische recht schreibt vor dass jedes
baugrundstück zunächst gründlich von archäologen teams untersucht werden muss was ein glück in diesem fall experten und expertinnen
vermuten dass der sarkophag wohl aus der zeit der ptolemäer stammt also von etwa 320 vor christus bis 30 vor christus
in der nähe des sarkophags wurde zudem eine büste gefunden die sehr stark verwittert ist ohne details erkennen zu können
geht man schwer davon aus dass sie den verstorbenen
darstellt und das lässt auf einen mann schließen doch wer genau könnte es sein ein zeitgenosse von
cleopatra der siebten der letzten königin des
bereichs und außerdem die geliebte von gaius julius caesar und marcus antonius
manche hoffen sogar darauf dass es sich um alexander den großen handelt und zeitlich würde es passen er starb wohl im juni
323 vor christus und soll in alexandria begraben worden sein die
experten und expertinnen schließen von der größe des sarkophags darauf dass es nicht nur den toten selbst sondern auch grabbeigaben
enthalten könnte diese werden dann wohl auch verraten ob es sich bei dem toten um einen hohen würdenträger handelt oder eben nicht doch jetzt war
die ernüchterung bei der eröffnung gross keine
grabbeigaben und auch nichts deutet auf ein könig hin der sarkophag ist unvollendet es gibt keine
liefen im sarkophag und das ist die zweite enttäuschung
wasser
wahrscheinlich über einen sehr langen zeitraum aus den umgebenden gebäuden in den sarkophag geschlossen außer knochen von insgesamt drei toten
enthält er nichts und die geben rätsel auf einer der toten wurde wohl von einem pfeil in den kopf getroffen ein kämpfer die anderen fleisch
kameraden aber warum dann ein so schwerer und großer
sauerland der deckel wie 15 tonnen ja es bleiben mehr fragen als antworten
und wenn ihr kein video zu diesen und anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die kaputte abo boxer auf youtube und verpasst kein video game awards
erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
vor jedem upload also vor jedem upload auf youtube also ihr kriegt den link einfach zuerst
und zwar vor allen anderen täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks und social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht mehr wisse dass die
genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken geheime kammer in der jobs pyramide bis dann
bleibt dran